what's up everybody thank you for  listening to riffing with Griffin make  sure you hit that subscribe hit that  like share check out my website  Eric grifter calm or especially riffing  with Griffin calm I want to thank  everybody who is uh supporting the show  especially people to send me fan art if  you would like to send me fan art this  is your opportunity you can send it to P  ol box three four three nine nine los  angeles california 90024 that's wrist  room with griffin p o-- box three four  three nine nine los angeles california  90024 and check out all my tour dates  I'm coming to Cobbs in San Francisco  Tempe Irvine improv coming to New York  levity live so make sure y'all check me  out and continue to watch Griffin WA  Griffin and don't forget about the  singer my  [Music]